the Joe Rogan experience what are your
thoughts on digital privacy what what do
you mean well like phones yeah like
phones like did you ever talk to someone
about something and then you see it in
your Google feed do you see ads oh yeah
so we don't I mean I haven't researched
this but my wife tells me we were once
gifted one of these you know what do you
call those things did you talk to oh
yeah well whoever the Google one is is
that Alexa no alexis is Amazon right so
it's Google at home and she says don't
turn that on I said why not cuz they'll
be listening and I didn't believe her at
first and then I started hearing stories
and so so I don't have one but it's not
because I know that it's listening or
not well substantiated there's been
actual they said they've apologized for
rational human contractors listening in
to conversations that people have had
having sex mm-hmm having arguments like
it's real yeah that seems like it should
be a problem what's your question to me
what am i all for it or my or what
what's your question no my question is
one of the things that you're getting
out of their ability to scan things is
they're tailoring things to your liking
like you know a phone tells you it's 22
minutes until you get home I get it
you're like [ __ ] how do you know where
I live exactly I didn't tell you where I
live I got here it is and I'm just
old-fashioned about this okay I'm get
off my lawn about this yeah I'm the old
man in the rocking chair on the porch
saying go Sonny get off my lawn but
you're also scientists okay but I don't
want to okay I wear multiple hats I'm
also a dad I'm also a husband I got all
these hats for all those things in this
particular case I'm old man and my old
man sensibility is if you track what I
shop at a store what would I buy at a
store and then send me coupons based on
what you think I'm gonna buy next based
on what I've bought before which is kind
of the same thing you're describing
you have denied me the chance of
stumbling upon something that I never
thought of buying and that takes away my
freedoms and I don't want that however
they denied you the chance of stumbling
upon something different it's not
diabolical it's just in the casual flow
of life I'll give an example I walk into
a wine shop hey can I help you
and I say if you help me find what I'm
looking for
it's a guarantee that I will never find
what I'm not looking for and I'll end up
spending less money in your wine shop
that's a weird way look it's the art of
browsing dude you're old enough to
remember when I got to look up this word
in a dictionary and you get through six
other words whoa I never knew that weird
let me read that you learn other words
on route to the word you're targeting I
understand okay wasn't that that is how
I feel and that's how I think about my
interaction with this world I'd like the
randomness the randomness of it enriches
my life and if you're gonna advertise to
me because you think you know who I am
maybe you do but I'll ultimately end up
spending less money because it's the
diversity of how I think and what I buy
and what I think of buying and how I buy
it and how much money I spend that is
the richness of the life I lead your
truck you're trying to channel me into
some product so some something that
fulfills a what I call it when they have
the the study whether you're going to
buy something or not the no no the the
table of people do you like this product
or not focus group yeah yeah am I just a
focus group to you if I am you don't
know me and I want to experience this
world by stepping where I've never
stepped before and buying something I've
never thought of buying and if you know
my previous habits you're assuming I'm
going to stay that way for the rest of
my life and maybe most people do and
maybe I might do that but if I do is
because I chose
- not because you have decided that
that's how I should be well don't you
think the stream it jumps are sorry
don't you think they're just doing that
because they think it would be effective
to advertise in that way so if you go
googling new Nikes and then as you're
looking at something in the Google ad
pops up and it's for new Nikes they said
hey Neal I know you were looking for
sorry sorry maybe I just need a little
nudge I mean it's not I don't think
that's that diabolical I'm the old man
on their porch I'm saying the next
generation might feel completely
different they might say I love it they
know exactly what I want you heard about
the case where they were that I read
this I haven't Rivera fide it but it's
completely plausible it was a teenage
girl who was googling pregnancy tests
because maybe she got pregnant okay and
the fact that she had searched pregnancy
test
she got coupons in the mail for baby
products and her parents said what are
the wide what is this she got outed
that's a little weird yeah but it's the
kind of thing that can happen that seems
that seems intrusive certainly because
pregnancy it's in every way no don't
tell me it's not intrusive because you
want to buy keys and you physical things
there's not just something that appears
on your Google feed you can quickly
glance over what's the difference we'd
send you mail to your mailbox and
filling your advertising space in front
of your face with product what's the one
other people can see it I've walked by
your computer I can see it don't look I
guess I'm arguing in principle rather
than in detail okay well let me take the
counterpoint in the on the positive side
what they're doing in terms of
particularly Google in terms of your
driving right and in terms of using of
Google Maps and documenting the history
of all these people driving and
especially with things like Waze which
they acquired as they've developed a
much more efficient product than Apple
which what Apple does the Apple Maps
they shred everything you do yes they do
they do they all where you've been and
where you're going that's correct but
Apple Maps sucks
so you have to because they don't have
enough data they don't have nearly the
amount of data Google has Billy what is
Google giving you that Apple Maps isn't
they're telling you you're 22 minutes
from home the time for you to drive home
was valuing that well yes and also it's
not okay map wait hold on their programs
far better I can ask it how long it'll
take me to go somewhere rather than it
knowing what my drop what my day time
schedule looks like and then coming in
like you said how do you know [ __ ] you
know I had that same reaction as you did
and I said I wonder why what's causing
this it's a little creepy and again I'm
the old man syndrome some a ten-year-old
kid that's only ever known this and
becomes 15 and 20 that is life to them
right why would they even maybe they're
not going to complain about it but I'm
the old man on the porch but yet I'm
saying it off my loss sort of
intrusiveness or at the very least this
connection that you have to these
devices and that they have to your
patterns and your information it seems
inevitable that doesn't mean I have to
welcome it with open arms but I agree
it's inevitable
[Applause]